[موسيقى]
مساء الخير في 30 نوفمبر الماضي توفى هنري
كيسنجر السياسي الامريكي المعروف عن عمر
يناهز ال 100 عام ووفاته مثل حياته اثارت
الكثير من الجدل ما بين يعني من شعر
بالحزن على رحيله باعتباره كان عبقريا
سياسيا لو كان موجودا كما يقول يعني
المتحمسون له لحل الكثير من المشكلات وما
بين الناقمين عليه والمنتقدين له وفي
الحالتين نحن في حاجه الى ان نتوقف عند
هنري كيسنجر بثه ان كان عظيما وان كان
معيبا وليس افضل عند الحديث عن هنري
كيسنجر من ان نستعين باستاذ علوم سياسيه
من الطراز الرفيع الدكتور علي الدين هلال
ليحدثنا عن هذا السياسي الامريكي الشهير
مساء الخير معال الدكتور مساء الخير اهلا
وسهلا استاذ سيد يعني هنري كيسنجر ده كثر
الحديث عنه كثيرا لكن هل ممكن ابدا محرك
التقيته على الاقل مره يعني نعم ا وهو كان
استاذ علوم سياسيه زي حضرتك هل ممكن قبل
ما نبدا نتكلم عن نقاط الخلاف في ارث هنري
كيسنجر نعرف الناس اولا من هو هنري كيسنجر
حاضر انا عايز اقول بس الخلاف اللي انت
اشرت اليه بين مؤيد ومعارض وغاضب
ومتحفظ وناقم هو بيوري ثراء حياه
كسنجر وبيور ان كيسنجر ترك بصمته على
التاريخ وانه فعل افعال هناك من يحبها
ويرضى عنها وهناك من
يرفضها وينق
عليها هنري
كيسنجر هو بحكم المولد
الماني وبالتالي يعني يجب ان يفهم المستمع
هو يهودي هو يهودي الماني في ايام النازي
ايام هتلر واضطهاد اليهود هاجرت اسرته الى
الولايات المتحده في عام
38 على طول يعني بعدها بثلاث سنين بياخد
الجنسيه
بعدها
ب يتم تجنيده في الجيش الامريكي وبحكم انه
بجيد الالمانيه بيشغلو مترجم في مخابرات
الجيش يعني الارجح مع المعتقلين
الالمان من ايام
الناجي محتاجين لمترجم يتكلم عملت ايه
عملت ايه الى اخ تحقيقات تحقيقات فاذا هو
هو حياته الماني اكتسب الجنسيه
الامريكيه بدايه عمله
بالجيش يعني بعد المدرسه الثانويه على
طول بعد كده يلتحق بجامعه
هارفد هارفرد دي من مثلا يعني في امريكا
في كده مجموعه جامعات بيسموها الاي في
ليج عدد جامعات لا يتجاوز اصابع اليدين
اللي هي نخبه النخب نخبه النخب
هارفرد
منها فيدخل هارفرد
ويتفوق بنعمل ماجستير فيها بنعمل
الدكتوراه
فيها في هذه الفتره كيسنجر كان له زملاء
كلهم بذه في الحياه العامه يعني هو كان
مين زملائه في في الدراسه
الجامعيه واحد اسمه ستانلي هوفمان
ده واحد من اعظم اساتذه العلاقات
الدوليه في امريكا والعالم
ككله تاني واحد واحد
اسمه سبيجو بريزنسكي اه ده اللي بقى
مستشار امن قومي لاحقا مظبوط في ايام
كارتر
ديمقراطي
الثالث ادي شلله التلمذه بتاعته صمويل
هانتنغتون اه المفكر الكبير الصدام
الحضاره الحضرات
نحن ده برض بيوريك بقى يعني البيئه
الثقافيه اللي هو والبيئه
العلميه ينجح
بتفوق في الجامعه
ديت يحضر
ماجستير ودهور بقى هو ايه بقى العقليه دي
عمل الماجستير بتاعه في معنى
التاريخ ذا مين
مقارنه في فلسفه التاريخ
بين شبنجلر مؤرخ الماني اسمه شبنجلر اللي
هو كتب على صعود وسقوط الدوله
الرومانيه و المؤرخ الانجليزي توبي اللي
له كتاب من 12 جزء اسمه ستادي اوف
ستور هو بص على كيف ف
اثنين من اعظم مؤرخي
العالم شبلر الالماني وتوبي الانجليزي كيف
فهم معنى العالم معنى التاريخ معنى
التاريخ خلص عمل
الدكتوراه وهنا ب نشوف بقى تكوينه
الفكري دور
القياده ما هو دور القياده في
تاريخ
واهتم باثنين من من وزراء الخارجيه دول
اللي كنت بسال حضرتك عليهم قبل ما نسجل ا
اتفضل برض واحد الماني وواحد انجليزي اه
خد بالك الماني اللي هو مترنيخ اه اللي هو
داهيه اه الانجليزي اسمه كاسلر اه وزير
خارجيه وبدا يشوف ازاي الاثنين دول تع مال
مع السياسه الخارجيه وحافظه على النظام
الدولي في فتره ما بعد انتهاء حروب
نابوليون
1815 اذا الراجل ده في عنده خلطه ما بين
الفلسفه والتاريخ
والسياسه هو استاذ علوم سياسيه ثم اصبح
استاذ للعلوم السياسيه في جامعه هارفرد
انما وهو بيشتغل في العلوم السياسيه ينظر
الى التاريخ والى
الفلسفه بعد كده بقى كتب عشرات
الكتب يعني هو مثلا في بدايه الستينات له
كتاب على الفورين بولسي السياسه الخارجيه
لامريكا هو طرح فيها افكار جديده في تحليل
السياسه
الخارجيه بعد يعني ن خ بالنا روح قديم قوي
في في 15 سنه الاخيره كان له كتاب على
الورلد اوردر النظام الع النظام العالمي
او وتحليله لوضع الدولي الراهن
ومستقبله بعد كده في سنه 22 طلع
كتابين
كتاب عن الذكاء الاصطناعي ومستقبل الجنس
البشري وهو عمره 99 سنه بيتكلم على مستقبل
العالم واثار فيه القضايا الاخل قيه اللي
بيثير الذكاء الاصطناعي ب له كتاب اسمه
القاده اه ست قاده ست قاده كان منهم انور
السادات بيتكلم على اه يعني هو كيف تعامل
مع الناس دول هو كيف يحلل خلفيتهم كيف
فهموا التاريخ كيف فهموا النظام
الدولي وكيف غيروا النظام الدولي لو سالت
حضرتك بعد
يعني النوبس او العرض السريع اللي عرض لنا
من هو كيسنجر ايه كانت الفكره او الافكار
الرئيسيه او
تصوره في السياسه الخارجيه اللي اهلته انه
يستدعى الى البيت الابيض في اواخر
الستينات ليكون مستشارا للامن القومي في
اداره نكسن ثم وزيرا للخارجيه حضرتك قلت
لي ايه يعني الافكار الناظه او
الحاكمه عنده انا هل
خصها في كلمه واحده او في
كلمتين
المصلحه و
الواقعيه وكلمتين هم وجهين لعمله واحده في
عام
9 يعني هو كان
لسه صدر كتاب كان لسه طفل اه
لاستاذ في جامعه شيكاغو اسمه هانز مورجن
ثاو
كتاب اسمه
امشن السياسه بين الامم او بين الدول اللي
هو
قال السياسه اللي في العالم دي كلها
علاقات الدول تقوم على اساس المصلحه
الوطنيه ولا في يعني يعني ان الافكار
والايديولوجيات والاديان
واي اعتبرا
حاجات تتشح بها السياسه الخارجيه لكن
موجهات السياسه الخارجيه هي المصلحه
المصلحه وانه الدول تتنافس فيما بينها على
اساس المصالح في التنافس ده كل دوله بتعمل
تراكم
لقوتها قوتها العسكريه قوتها الاقتصاديه
وبالتالي هذا التنافس يؤدي الى نوع من
توازن
اذا تحقق توازن
القوه بيحدث استقرار في العالم ما حدث
يحدث الاضطراب اذا الفكره الحاكمه عند بقى
كيسنجر واضح ان تؤثر بهز مورجانثو وطور
افكاره فبيقول ايه اذا اردت ان
تدرس دوله من الدول اذا اردت ان تحلل موقف
دولي معين حرب معينه ازمه دوليه معينه
عليك ان تنظر اخي الاستاذ سيد الى
الوقائع الى
الاحداث الى الحقائق كما هي على الارض
وليس الامنيات ولا تخلط بين هذا انك بتحب
الطرف ده وبتكر الطرف
التاني ولا انت تتمنى فوز الف ولا ضعف
ب من هذا
التحليل
الواقعي لعناصر القوه
للاطراف انت تقول طب بقى انا مصلحه بلدي
فين انا مصلحه بلدي فين وهل مصلحه بلدي ان
انا تعميق الخلاف والنزاع ولا اطفاؤه
الوصول الى الحل
اه يمكن بقى هو ده الجانب اللي بعض الناس
يتهموه باللا اخلاقيه ايمورال مور بس هو
يعني انا اقوللك في حاجه تانيه بقى لا كان
مورال فيها ا
هو بيقول الواقعيه انظر انت السياسه
الدوليه عالم خطر جيوش اسلحه موت
مدمار غزه
مثال يعني لما بتخش في مجال السياسه هو
مجال حافل
بالاخطار ولما توصل بقى لدرجه
اعلى قاذفات قنابل سلا
نووي اسلحه دمار
شامل
اذا يعني اذا جاز في موضوعات اخرى
نجرب نقول كلام لا نقصده لا في مجال
الاستراتيجيه
والحرب وعندما تكون انت بتنتمي الى دوله
عظمى للولايات
المتحده يعني ممكن واحد في دوله الصغيره
يقول عايز يقوله بقى ما ما فيش مش مؤثر اه
لما ما انت
تبقى رجل لك صوت ولك تاثير في دوله عظمى
لا بيبقى كل كلمه بحساب وكل كلمه طيب
وبالتالي قال انا يعني يعني ق ح كذا كذا
مثل بقى الواقيه دي ادت بيه الى ايه ادت
بيه
انه هو هو مستشار امن قومي هو الذي خطط
ونفذ اعتراف امريكا بالصين
الشعبيه وعايز نشرح يعني ايه يا ريت في
ناس ما كانش اه الصين لما انشات الامم
المتحده سنه 44 الصين كان بيحكمها حاكم
تاني اسمه شيانج
كاشيك وكان له حزب هو رئيس حزب الكومن
تانج كان حزب مليء بالمشاكل والفساد الى
اخره طلع ضده ثوره اللي هي ثوره الحزب
الشيوعي الصيني بقضه ماوس تونج ماوس تونج
من قبلها ب 20 سنه بدا عمليه ا زحف عسكري
زي حرب شعبيه وبدا ياخد الصين قطعه قتع
طيب لما انشات امم المتحده مين الصين مين
حاكم الصين هي فاصبح مقعد الامم المتحده
ومقعد مجلس الامن يحتله شان كشيك طيب موت
س تونج في 1 نوفمبر 49 خلاص سيطر على
الصين شكشيك هرب على جزيره تيوان جزيره
كان اسمها فرموزه فرموزه فكان اسمها كانها
حكومه فرموزه فرموزه دي اصبحت هي التي
تحتل مقعد الصين وظلت هكذا وظلت هكذا وكل
دول غربيه لا تعترف
اصلا بحكومه
بكين كيس الجرار
هو اللي دبر كان وها اسمها مباراه في
البينج بونج بين الفريق الامريكي وفريق
الصين ب دبلوماسيه البينج بونجين هو عمل
زياره سريه للصين هو حرك تشير الى انه
فريق امريكي لعب مباراه مع الفريق الصيني
فهو استغل هذه يعني المناسبه وربما دبر
لها ربما دبر الله علشان يزور الصين يعني
او يذوب الجليد تمهي لزار الصين راح زار
الصين سنه 70 سريه في عام
1972 يزور الرئيس الامريكي نيكسون الصين
ويعلن خلاص اعتراف الولايات المتحده بان
الصين الشعبيه هي الممثل الشرعي لصين لكل
الصين و
ا
تايوان تخرج بقى من الامم المتحده خالص
وتشغل
مكانها طيب ايه
قال ايه ارى قلتلك التاريخ والجغرافيه
وكذا وقال ان لا يمكن لامريكا انها تتجاهل
الصين ان الصين هي قوه صاعده في
التاريخ وان على امريكا ان
تحترمها وتعترف
بمصالحها
ومن ثم نقطه البدايه هي العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه عايز اقوللك بقى حاجه طريفه
جدا في يوليو الماضي في اطار احتفاله ب
100 سنه ذهب لزياره ال وقابل الرئيس
الصيني وقابل الرئيس الصيني وفتح هتلاق كل
الابواب لدرجه مسؤول امريكاني قال نحن
نستغرب انه في الوقت اللي ان الصين لا
تفتح ابوابها للمسؤولين الامريكيين
استقبل مواطن امريكي برايفت سزن مواطن
مواطن عادي امريكي مثل هذه الحواف مثل
الحفاوه وبين قال ايه بقى عمل تصريحات ده
كيسنجر كيسنجر اه هوو ابن الئه ابن الب اه
قال انه اذا في حرب في العالم
عالميه تكون هتبقى بين الصين وامريكا وان
على امريكا ان تتحاشى هذا بقدر الا كان ده
هتبقى مدمره
لها ماذا تريد الصين ده السؤال اللي قاله
لنفسه الصين
تريد الاحترام
والتقدير ان امريكا لا تنظر لها على انها
دوله من العالم الثالث دوله جنوب دوله مش
عارف لونها ايه
انها قوه
متكافئه وانه يجب على امريكا ده كلام
كيسنجر كله انها تتفهم ما مخاوف
الصين ان تتفهم مخاوف الصين وان الصين هي
اصيح قويه الى اخره لكن هي عندها مشاكل
امنيه بتحكم مليار من البشر بمشاكل
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وثنيه
وعراقيه والاكبر خطر ان امريكا تصعد من
خلافها مع الصين ليه شوف بقى دي بقى
الواقعيه بقى القحه قال كل ما امر تضغط
على الصين فالصين هتقرب من روسيا
اه يبقى في
تحالف يعني خطر على امريكا هو كانه راي
غريب جدا راي غريب جدا اللي
هو ان هناك تناقضات وخلافات ما بين الصين
وروسيا خد بالك هو في حدود مشتركه طبعا
حوالي 3 4000 كيلو اه والحدود دي فيها
ندره سكانيه
روسيه وفر من السكان
الصين وبيتكلم
على اختلافات في التاريخ وفي الجغرافيا
الى اخره ومره قال كده انا قبلت في
حياتي
مئات الروس لم اشاهد واحد منهم يشيد
بالصين الله اعلم صحيح ولا مش صحيح ده كان
فكره حاكمه عنده ان على امريكا ان تستثمر
ان تنتهز ما اعتبره هو تناقض خلافات الى
اخر هي نقطه الحدود بس للتوضيح ركب تشير
الى انه البعض بيعتقد ان ممكن العدد
الوافر من السكان على الجانب الصيني قد
يزحف الى الحدود الروسيه اه طبعا كنوع من
يعني مش شجره قصريه ولا حاجه ارض فاضيه
ارض
فاضيه روسيا حاجه تانيه غريبه
جدا انت عارف امريكا اخر في ايام بوش
كلينتون وبوش وبعدها اتبعوا حاجه اسمها
سياسه نشر
الديمقراطيه يعني فرض الديمقراطيه عشناها
في الم طبعا ف في مصر كل البلاد وعملوا
مشروطيه اقتصاديه ل لو انت يا مصر عايزه
امريكا تساعد اقتصاديا عليكي تعملي كذا
وكذا
وكذا وبلغ الجبروت بتاعهم قال احد مظاهر
الديمقراطيه المجتمع المدني وانت يا مصر
يا وزاره شؤون اجتماعيه يعني احنا ما انت
بتدي ان هم اذا عملوا
مساعدات خاصه بالمجتمع المدني هم يدوها
مباشره وعملوا يعني بلا فورم كده يعني
شكليه طب نعمل لجنه من
المصريين هي اللي تقرر وطبعا
اللجنه مش مثله الحكومه وطبعا يؤسفنا اقول
في وقت مصر
قبلت وفي كثير من الدول العربيه يعني في
مشروطيه اقتصاديه وفي مشروطيه
سياسيه عايز كذا غيرلي في كذا غيرون
الاحزاب
بتاعك ادي حريه اكبر لجمعيات معينه الى
اخره هو اعترض على هذه السياسه
كسنجر قال
ده ده كلامه هو ده ده فرض للثقافه الغربيه
على
شعوب ومجتمعات وثقافات اخرى ق انا واقعي
الواقعيه انك تنظر الى العالم فتكتشف ان
فيه تعدديه
ثقافيه الثقافه الاسيويه غير الثقافه
العربيه غير الثقافه
الافريقيه غير ثقافه اوروبا امريكا هناك
تعدد للثقافات وهناك تعدد في اولويات سلم
ترتيب القيم من دوله لاخرى وثقافه لاخرى
اخرى فاللي انت بتعمليه يا امريكا ويا غرب
هو سياسه خاطئه انت تريد ان تفرض
اولوياتك على بلاد تانيه الواقعيه ادي بقى
هنا برض مافيش مورتي هو مالوش دعوه ان
حقوق الانسان ده يعني اللي بيسع الى نشر
بيقول لك لا دي دي قيمه عليا يجب ان تكون
في كل الدنيا هو بيقول انا ماليش دعوه اذا
البلاد دي يعني انك بتروح الصين وكذا
القيمه العليا هي الجماعه مش فرد يعني
بينما الثقافه الغربيه فرديه فرديه هناك
كومتان الجماعه الجماعه تاتي قبل الفرض
ا فقال انا برفض هذه السياسه وان احنا
ممكن نعمل توعيه لكن على شعوب هذه البلاد
ان تختار شكل النظم السياسيه
والاقتصاديه اللي هم عايزينها وليس من حق
الغرب فرد في يعني ف الواقعيه بتاعته ادته
ادت بيه الى قبول فكره التعدديه الثقافيه
والتعدديه الحضاريه وانه ليس من المناسب
فرض قيم او ثقافه على الاخرين بهذه
الخلفيه باعتباره رياليست يعني او واقعي
واستاذن حضرتك للتوضيح يعني لغير
المتابعين العلاقات الدوليه فيها مدارس
مختلفه واحد من هذه المدارس ان تكون
واقعيا يعني ان تقتنع زي ما كيسنجر كده زي
ما معالي الدكتور قال يقول انه ما يحرك
الدول هي المصالح وهي تحقق هذه المصالح
بقدر ما تملك من ادوات القوه الاعتبارات
الدينيه الاعتبارات الاخلاقيه اي اعتبارات
اخرى قد تكون موجوده لكن الاساس هو
المصلحه مظبوط مع الدكتور نعم طب معالي
الدكتور بعد معرفتنا بهذه الخلفيه هل ممكن
اسال حضرتك سؤالين اخيران اهم انجازاته
على مدار السنوات الطويله الماضيه مع
العلم طبعا احنا كلنا عارفين ان هو بعد ما
ترك البيت الابيض في منتصف السبعينات هو
قدم استشارات لكل الادارات الامريكيه التي
لحقت ذلك يعني ولدول العالم وكثير من دول
العالم ومن الصين الع هو كان عنده شركه
شركه خاصه لتقديم الاستشار السياسيه
كيسنجر اسوشيتس اه شوف بص يعني هعمل
عناوين اول
عنوان اللي هو عمله في
كمبوديا في كمبوديا كان في فئه
متطرفه
ايديولوجيا وسياسيا اسمها الخمير
الحمر الخمير
الحمر يعني مش يعني مش بس زي اي نظام
شيوعي لا فضاع في مجازر وكذا
وكذا هو خد القرار واقنع الحكومه
الامريكيه بتدخل الجيش الامريكي لاسقاط
النظام دود
وحدث في اواخر
ال0 69 70 اه ادي اول يعني خطوه جريئه بيت
هي تشكيل التوازنات في اسيا وطبعا وقتها
اسقاط نظام شيوعي معناها اخضاب للاتحاد
السوفيتي معنا اغضاب للصين الش اثنين اللي
احنا اشرنا اليه
ا ادخال الصين في الامم المتحده واعاده
بناء
تاسيس السياسه الخارجيه والعلاقات
والاعتراف السياسي
والدبلوماسي بين الولايات المتحده والصين
على حساب تيوان على حساب
تيوان الحاجه الثالثه
كيسنجر هو اللي اخرج امريكا من مساه
فيتنام كان الجيش الامريكي
متورط ادي بقى الواقعيه في عنفوانها هو
شايف بلده دخل الحرب هو ادرك على طول لا
انتصار في هذه الحرب لا
انتصار برض عشان نبقى يعني يعني فيتنام دي
كان بالدولتين في الخمسينات والستينات كان
في دولتين دوله اسمها فيتنام الجنوبيه
صبتها سيجون ودي دوله مواليه للغرب وفي
دوله اسمها فيتنام الشماليه مدعومه من
الاتحاد
السوفيتي والصين في
الستينيات بدا يظهر مجموعه بتحارب ضد
حكومه فيتنام الجنوبيه بدعم من فيتنام
الشماليه الفيت
كونج الامريكان دخلوا
لنصره النظام التابع لهم حرب حرب احدثه
انشقاق داخليه اجتماعيه خطيره جو امريكا
لان استمرت سنوات طويله استمرت سنوات
طويله هو كده بص على
الصوره فاكتشف ده استنزاف منظم
لبلده ب ادي الخطوره بقى الواقعيه ممكن
تؤدي الى ايه لابد ان احنا نتفاوض مع
فيتنام
الشماليه نعمل معاها هدنه ونسحب قوتنا ولا
مؤاخذه فلتذهب فيتنام الجنوبيه الى الجحيم
حالفهم خلاص
بقى خد بالك ده اللي امريكا عملته بعد ب
20 سنه في افغانستان افغانستان الله بعدها
باكتر اه اه فايه اللي حصل 50 سنه اه ايه
اللي
حصل حصلت مفاوضات غير
مباشره سحب الجيش
الامريكي ب طبعا بقى بعملائه بانصار الى
اخره
و ماعرفش بقى اذا كان الاخوه يدروا يجيبوا
صور اه طبعا طب في صور لطياره هليكوبتر
مثلا والفيتنام متعاونين معاهم يمسكوا في
الطياره فتبقى الطياره طالعه اه ومعاها
وده اللي حصل في افغانستان برض بعضهم ناس
خايفين من طالبان وبعضهم كانوا من حلفاء
الامريكان الواقعيه ادت الى دي حرب خسرانه
وما هموش يتقال ان امريكا انهزمت
ماموش يعني هو يعني عايزين نتامل في معاني
دوت ان هو افضل له ان يقال ان امريكا خسرت
هذه المعركه عن
انه امريكا تظل
تستنزف اموال وافراد واسلحه لعش سنوات
اخرى انا اذكر معال الدكتور انه في
السبعينات اثناء حواراته مع نيكسون يعني
وارجو ان تصححي كان وجهه نظره تعال نعلن
النصر باي منطق ونعلن الانسحاب حققنا ما
ارضنا ونسحب مضبوط كده مبوط طب في سؤال ما
اقدرش يعني انهي الحلقه دون ان اسالك عليه
هنري كيسنجر كانت له اسهامات مؤثره في
الشرق الاوسط والصراع العربي الاسرائيلي
يعني حضرتك كيف تلخص دوره او اهم قراراته
ومساهماته في هذا الصراع نور دور مخرب هو
للاسف انتصر يعني هو
حقق ما
يريده انما اذى
واضر بالقضيه
العربيه
هو
اولا يعني احنا خدنا الحرب
اكتوبر 6 اكتوبر
73 هو ج زر مصر على ديسمبر وقابل الرئيس
السادات الرئيس دات قالله كان الرئيس دات
يعني شايل كتير من الروس فقال لله احنا
دعنا لا يتحدث في الماضي في الوقت ده
ماكانش في علاقات دبلوماسيه بينا وبين
امريكا على مستوى السفراء في قائم مكتب
رعايه مصالح قال له ده نتحدث عن مستقبل
المنطقه فكان في قبول من الرئيس
المصري انه عايز يتقرب الى امريك المتحده
وفي هذا الوقت اذكر ان كيسنجر طار مقابله
محمد حسين هيكل كاتب المصري الشهير
والاستاذ محمد حسنين هيكل كتب ايه اللي
دار في النقاش واختلفوا في ايه واتفقوا في
ايه بس ده بره موضوعنا دلوقتي
ايه الافكار
الحاكمه لكيسنجر رقم واحد انه عايز فض
الاشتباك بين مصر
واسرائيل الجيشين ملتحمين حك بتتكلم ده
بعد 73 بعد 73 اه هو مالوش دور عندنا قبل
كده ما حضرتك قلت ان هو يعني ق حضرتك قلت
جاه في اول السبعينات في ديسمبر في ديسمبر
اه احنا ج بعد بد اه في ديسمبر هقوللك اه
يعني بس حد تفصيلات كتيره ق هو
مصر
ارسلت الله يرحمه
الاستاذ جنرال حافظ
اسماعيل الامن القومي
للسادات وقابل كيسنجر مرتين مره في واشنطن
ومره في
باريس كانت مصر قبل
الحرب بدات في ظل خط تفكر طب يعني احنا لو
هنعمل
تسويه شكلها
ايه بتكلم على
72 فحافظ اسماعيل بدا يقوله والله يعني
الرئيس والقياده المصريه مستعده تعمل كذا
مستعده تعمل
كذا محضر الاجتماع الاجتماعين دول كان من
صفحه قام كيسنجر
بعمل انا مش عايز اوصفه اوصاف شديده يعني
انما عمل غير اخلاقي غير دبلوماسي انه سلم
هذا المحضر الى اسرائيل لقاءاته مع حفظ
اسماعيل فده معناه
اسرائيل قبل ما انت عد تتفاوض معاها هي
عارفه اخرك ايه بتفكر في ايه فاذا هي
هتعتبر اللي انت قبله ده نقطه بدايه وتضغط
عليك اكترر عشان تدي اكتر ادي الفكره لما
انا اكون عارف ان انت يا سيد قلت لحد حد
بلغني انت ممكن تقبل كذا خلاص بقى انا مش
هعتبر عتبر انت عملته ده نقطه
البدايه الحد الادن اضغط عليك المهم لما ج
في ديسمبر طبعا عارف الكلام ده بعد
كده ضغط على كذا وفي هذا الوقت طلع بقى
اسمها الدبلوماسيه
المكوكيه المكوك رايح جاي رايح جاي انتقل
كيسنجر ما بين القاهره وتل ابيب عشرات
المرات قبل ولا بعد الحرب لا بعد كل
لقاءات حافظ اسماعيل كانل 72 ثم يعني بس
استاذك هي جمله يعني اطع حضرتك في لحظه
بعد بقات حافظ اسماعيل مع هنري كيسنجر في
باريس وواشنطن اصفرت عن قناعه السارات ان
ما يقدمه او هنري كيسنجر لا يكفي انه يعدل
عن قراره بالحرب فبدات الحرب اكتر من كده
يعني
ا بعض الناس بيروا ان
كيسنجر اوحى الى مصر لا تحارب او ان
امريكا لا تمانع ان مصر تعمل عمل عسكري
اللي هي العباره الشهيره اللي هو قالها ق
ان هذه القضيه قضيه
ميته لابد يحدث
سخونه حتى اتدخل ادي برض الواقعيه الشديده
انت قضيته ق ميته من
67 اسرائيل متحكمه ومسيطره
ومعربه اعمل حاجه عشان اقدر ادخل ادي
كلامه ان هذه قضيه ميته
بارده انا اتدخل فقط في القضايا الساخنه
اللي هي بتهدد السلم والامن الدوليين فبت
دخل هل انا واضح يا استاذ سيد جدا طيب جدا
يعني بعض الناس بيوا ان هو يعني معناه ان
امريكا لا تمانع وبالتالي اكتوبر ديسمبر
جه مصر وهو اللي عمل الدبلوماسيه الكوكيا
بين القاهره وتل ابيه وكان له مساهمه
فعاله في خلق المناخ السياسي لفضل
الاشتباك الاول والتاني بعد كده بقى ب بقى
المفاوضات بين العرب
واسرائيل عشان نحل يعني او الكلام كده هو
طلع بكذا
نظريه سواء في مصر اولا قال حكايه العرب
دي ما مافيش مفاوضات بين دوله وسبع دول
تانيه اه بين دوله و دوله ودوله دوله
ودوله جزا
جزا مسار الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي يكون
سوري اسرائيلي اردني اسرائيلي وده اللي
تمسكت به اسرائيل حتى اللحظه مصري
اسرائيلي انا بس عايز يقول حاجه لو احنا
بنفض كار مع بعض فكلنا بخش الجلسه مع بعض
ومتفقين هنقدر نقول ايه و نقولش ايه ايا
كان لما كل واحد بيقعد لوحده بتضع الثلاثه
دول او الاربعه في موقع
تنافسي يعني كل واحد عايز يحصل على اكبر
جزء مايهموش الاخرين عملوا
ايه بيجعل اسرائيل طرف الاقو في المفاوضات
هي تعلم ماذا يدور مع ده ومع ده ومع
ده الاخطر من كده بقى قال طب حكايه بقى حل
الصراع كده يعني مره واحده كلام مش مش
مفهوم خطوه
خطوه فجزا الصراع من الاطراف بحيث يبقى في
مفاوضات بين اسرائيل وكل دوله عربيه على
حدها ثم في داخل كل دوله
عربيه قاللك هننجز ال
موضوعيا اه يعني نبدا مثلا بسينا نبدا لا
حتى لا خط كذا الخط كذا وين لا اه اه ان
احنا يعني تتفاوض شويه انت هتعمل كذا
اسرائيل هنسحب كذا مقابل انت هتعمل كذا
اسرايل ه تنسحب كذا انت تعمل كذا ف اللي
احنا نقوله ب تجزئه الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي او المفاوضات العربيه
الاسرائيليه من حيث الاطراف بقت كل ل دوله
على حده ومن حيث
الموضوعات واسرائيل اعتبرت هو ده
الاستراتيجيه المثله للتفاوض مع العرب
والتزمت بها حتى الان فهو
يعني هتيجي بقى يعني لما تيجي تقيمه
ا التقييم هيختلف انا مين اه
ا يعني اسرائيل تقدره اسرائيل تقدره يجوز
بعض الناس في مصر بيقوللك احنا نفدنا
باراضي اه احنا لو كنا ربطنا نفسنا بحاجات
تانيه اه بالمسار الفلسطيني والسوري وغير
السوري توقف اه فانت كون ان انت عملت
مخاضات مباشره
و يعني في بعض المصريين لهم هذا الراي اه
وان ط بص كان ممكن وساعات يتقال ف لو كنا
كده كان زماننا زي الجولان او حاجه زي كده
يعني يعني اراء مختلفه وفي ط و طبعا بعض
الناس بيعتبر ان هو قوى الطرف الاسرائيلي
ان هو يعني جعل الطرف الاسرائيلي هو الطرف
الذي يدير العلاقات مع كل دول العربيه
بينما كل دوله
عربيه لا تعرف الا ما يدور بينها وبين
اسرائيل وزي ما قلت وضع الدول العربيه في
مواقع تنافسيه كل دوله تريد ان تحصل من
اسرائيل على اكبر قدر و بالالي تنافست دول
العربيه وانتهى الوضع الوضع اللي احنا
قاعدين فيه يعني الوضع الراهن هو ثمره
لدبلوماسي
كيسنجر في المنطقه اللي اسسها كيسنجر في
المنطقه واستمرت بعد كده اصبح بقى جزء من
الفهم الامريكي يعني حتى حضرتك لما كانت
في مفاوضات في وقت مبكر
ا اسرائيليه فلسطينيه فالف فصين جايين بع
مطالب وضع القدس وضع اللاجئين عوده
اللاجئين المياه الابار قول لا لا لا لا
نمسك قضيه
قضيه قضيه قضيه لما نحلها ونقول انت احنا
هنعمل كذا وانتم تعملوا كذا تبقى ننتقل
لغيرها ا وظهر تعيش انت بقى العمر معانا
بالظبط ظهرت مفاهيم في الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ا يعني لازم نتوقف ظهر في فتره
من فت
تعبير كونكتف
امجي الغموض البناء يعني يقوللك معلش انت
احنا في 10 حاجات بس في حاجات صعبه مالهاش
حل او صعبه جدا ده الامريكان بيقولوا كده
والاسرائيليين زي مثلا حق الفلسطين في
العوده
ا ف خلي خلي المشاكل الحاده في الاخر ابدا
بالسهل واعمل
غموض سموه بقى الغموض البناء لا ترفض ولا
تقبل ونستنى شويه ا التاريخ اسبت ان
الغموض البناء ادى الى الدخول في طريق
مسدود انا بعتقد ان دور كيسنجر في الشرق
الاوسط هو قفد بلده مافيش كلام يعني
والمفروض هو الراجل بيخدم بلده وزير خالد
بلده او مستش او حتى مواطن خاص بيخدم بلده
اثنين خدم اسرائيل اك التضرر الرئيسي
ا رقم واحد الفلسطينيين ثم دول العربيه
ربنا يخليك مع الدكتور انا عندي بس ملحوظه
اخيره لما جاء مارتن اندك وهو دبلوماسي
امريكي يهودي وكتب كتابا عن كيسنجر اظن من
ثلاث اربع سنين اه اسمه سيد اللعبه اه
بالضبط كده سيد اللعبه ا وهو قال في
الكتاب وقال لي قال هو كان يحب يقذف الكره
الى الامام المشاكل اللي يمكن تاجيلها لا
تحل الانشغال بحلها الان ناجلها بعدين لما
تصبح قضيه سخنه زي ما عمل في 73 كده صح
المشكله بقى اللي بتاجل ده بتاجل الى ما
لا نهايه نهايه تتعقد
الامور التمن تكلفه الحل
بتزيد ايا كان يعني هو رجل
دبلوماسي
داهيه درس سلوك وزراء الخارجيه والدول درس
تطور التاريخ وصل الى مجموعه من
الاقتناع دفع عنها كاستاذ جامعه ثم
مارسها ودي بقى قوته قوته انه خلافا لاغلب
اساسه الجامعه زملائه في امريكا او غيره
اللي هم عمرهم ما تقلدوا منصب تنفيذي فظلت
افكارهم افكار نظريه يعني هو قدر ينزل
افكاره الى ارض الواقع الى ارض الواقع
فله ما له وعليه ما عليه واعتقادي هيظل
محل جدل
وخلاف سنوات طويله قادمه جزيل الشكر معال
الدكتور شكرا
جزيلا شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ومع الدكتور
علي الدين هلال ان شاء الله نلتقي معه في
حلقات اخرى باذن الله الى اللقاء